hey this is interesting the other day a
guy told me to suck a bag of dicks that
was interesting I never heard that
before total stranger told me to suck a
bag of dicks he was angry ninjas suck a
bag of dicks like a greeting like a
baguette excuse ah
thank you very much it's a lovely day
for sucking several bags of dicks now
what happened was like I cut him off in
traffic it's just one of those things
where it's just I had to get in and no
one was in my car to judge me and I just
[ __ ] it
it's just decided he's not me so I don't
care what happens to him I'm just a
shitty thing to do it was bad cuz he was
coming fast cuz he didn't imagine in a
million years someone could be that big
of an [ __ ]
and so when I did it he had to slam on
his brakes and his dog went from the
windshield is really very bad very bad
and the worst part is when you cut
people up there they don't manage
they're behind you now so looking back
and he's like he's so mad and he keeps
trying to get next to me cuz he just
wants to see my [ __ ] face he's just
dies like I gotta see this [ __ ]
now I got to see the [ __ ] face of the
piece of [ __ ] that just did that to me
and I keep cutting them off cuz I don't
want him to see I'm ashamed of what I do
know you don't
finally we get to a red light and I
gotta face him only because there's a
car in front of me otherwise I would
have [ __ ] blown right through there
but there he is just furious and I'm
like hey I know it was awful I shouldn't
I don't know I'm not mad I was wrong why
what have you met and he's like [ __ ] you
and then he starts going like this
because he wants me to roll my window
down like I'm supposed to tape parted my
own abuses during this argument over oh
sorry I don't want to miss this what do
you have to say about me yes I rooted me
to shut out your anger with Mike so I
did I rolled it down I'm interested and
he goes hey [ __ ] I'm like yeah he
says suck a bag of dicks
then he drove away and I was kind of sad
that he drove away because I had a lot
of questions
that concept of sucking a bag of dicks
just weird like first of all when you
picture a bag of dicks what do you see
when you picture a bag of dicks is it
like a plastic bag and they're all
mushing together like chicken parts with
a date written on it with Sharpie keep
it in the freezer or is it like a paper
bag and they're sticking like baguettes
kind of like you went shopping bring it
home the bag of dicks for the kids go
Susie take a blue one they were hanging
in a window somewhere give me two of
those and how do you suck a bag of days
what does he want me to do does you want
me to take a bag of dicks and suck it
like suck the side of the bag or does he
want me to open the bag and suck each
dick individually and throw the used
ones in a bowl I get a mommy shells like
that so I have to make them all come you
know like how you can't answer a kid's
question they don't accept any answer a
kid never goes oh thanks I get it they
[ __ ] never say that they just keep
coming more questions why why why well
you don't even know who the [ __ ] you are
anymore at the end of the conversation
it's an insane deconstruction it's a
mate this is my daughter the other day
she's like Papa why can't we go outside
well cuz it's raining why well water's
coming out of the sky why because it was
in a cloud why well clouds form when
there's vapor
why I don't know I don't know that's oh
I don't know any more things those are
all the things I know why because I'm
stupid okay I'm stupid
why well because I didn't pay attention
in school okay I went to school but I
didn't listen in class why cuz I was
high all the time I spoke too much hot
why because my parents gave me no
guidance they didn't give a [ __ ] why cuz
they [ __ ] in a car and had me and they
resented me for taking their youth why
because they had bad morals they just
had no compass why cuz they had shitty
parents it just keeps going like that
why cuz [ __ ] it we're alone in the
universe nobody gives a [ __ ] about us
I'm gonna stop here to be polite to you
for a second but this goes on for hours
and hours and it gets so weird and
abstract at the end it's like why well
because some things are and some things
are not why well because things that are
not can't be
why because then nothing wouldn't be you
can't have [ __ ] nothing isn't
everything is why cuz if nothing wasn't
there'd be [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ]
that we don't like giant ants with top
hats dancing around there's no room for
all that [ __ ] why I'll [ __ ] you eat your
french fries you little [ __ ] god dammit
you know you have your bad thoughts
hopefully you don't you do good fittings
everybody has a competition in their
brain of good thoughts and bad thoughts
hopefully they were the good thoughts
win for me I always have both I have
liked the thing I believe the good thing
that's the thing I believe and then
there's this thing and I don't believe
it
but it is there it's always this thing
and then this thing it's become a
category at my brain that I call of
course but maybe I'll give you an
example okay like of course of course
children who have nut allergies need to
be protected of course we desegregate
their food from nuts have their
medication available at all times and
anybody who manufactures or serves food
needs to be aware of deadly nut
allergies of course but maybe maybe if
touching and nut kills you you're
supposed to die
of course not of course not
of course not Jesus I have a nephew who
has that I'd be devastated if something
happening here but maybe if we all just
do this for one year we're done with nut
allergies forever not of course if
you're fighting for your country and you
get shot or hurt it's a terrible tragedy
of course but maybe maybe if you pick up
a gun and go to another country and you
get shot it's not that weird maybe if
you get shot by the dude you were just
shooting at it's a tiny bit your fault
[Applause]
of course of course slavery is the worst
thing that ever happened listen listen
you all clapped for dead kids with the
nuts for kids dying from from nuts you
applauded so you're in this with me MAV
you understand you don't get to
cherry-pick
those kids did nothing to you
of course of course slavery is the worst
thing that ever happened of course it is
every time it's happened black people in
America Jews in Egypt every time a whole
race of people has been enslaved it's a
terrible terrible thing of course but
maybe maybe every incredible human
achievement in history was done with
slaves every single thing where you go
how did they build those pyramids they
just threw human death and suffering at
them until they were finished how did we
traverse the nation with a railroad so
quickly we just threw Chinese people in
caves and blew them up and didn't give a
[ __ ] what happened to them there's no
end of what you can do when you don't
get a [ __ ] about particular people you
can do anything
that's where human greatness comes from
is that we're shitty people that we [ __ ]
others over even today how do we have
this amazing micro technology because
the factory were they're making these
they jump off the [ __ ] roof cause
it's a nightmare in there you really
have a choice you can have candles and
doesn't be a little kinder to each other
or let someone suffer immeasurably far
away just so you can leave a mean
comment on YouTube while you're taking a
[ __ ]
[Applause]